et ils vous aimez oui oui c'est quelque
chose de moderne en tout cas ça se passe
un an jour on peut pas vraiment
l'ignorait mais vous attendez c'est bien
on l'a trop de bonnes réactions
tout le monde aime bien on a besoin
d'avoir un peu la vie des deux côtés et
donc vous allez dire que vous l'aimez
pas du tout comme ça nous ça nous permet
d'équilibrer le sujet 1 mademoiselle on
tourne mademoiselle que pensez vous de
ce spin off
j'aime pas trop quoi en fait rire pas
vraiment je crois que non ils essayent
mais il arrive pas physiquement vous le
trouvez comment
il n'est pas génial et en plus je crois
qu'il fait mal est fait très mal son
travail
sainz est un titre trop drôle je n'ai
pas vu sur scène mais ce que j'ai aperçu
la télévision est très bien mais si on
fait un sujet sur lui mais tout le monde
aime bien on est un petit peu dans la
merde là monsieur ça tourne monsieur que
pensez-vous de smaïn j'aime pas du tout
il est arrivé trop vite il a été un peu
on pulsé si vous aviez quelque chose à
lui dire en face ce serait quoi lui dire
en face
hyper désagréable qui retourne chez lui
messieurs si vous aviez quelque chose à
dire en face à ce mail ce serait quoi
qui retourne chez lui bah en fait à vrai
dire j'aime pas trop en fait oui une
botte pas tellement c'est son genre je
pense un peu vulgaire quoi bas en plus
il ya une vraie tête de con ils aurient
vie lamentables nuls
il est grossier vulgaire il se moque de
tous respectent rien je n'aime pas
passer il est en passe de mâts je crois
que je passerai au visage
même pas encore mais ils m'ont cassé on
voit comment sont les gens
voilà des gens qui veulent bien de bien
de tuer ni un recueil en 30 secondes et
s'achète les gens mais pas du tout mais
ça s'achète les gens mais pas du tout il
suffit que tu penses pas à lui mais
parce que dans ma comme s'ils sont sûrs
de passer à la télé ah ben là c'est sûr
ils sont achetés à la tv c'est dommage
parce que d'abord la première elle a
l'air sympa du club et ça a été dur pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou